hey friends and welcome back to rapid
fire language learning today we're
answering the question how to get
unstuck when you get stuck in language
learning
here's the thing language learning is a
long road and there are
obstacles on the way and it's completely
normal to get
stuck so how do you get unstuck well if
you get stuck
it means that the universe is sending
you a very precise signal then you have
to change something
either you have to change the materials
you're using the people
you're talking to the activities you're
engaging in
or the way you do these activities no
matter what you have to change there is
beauty
and growth in change and every sort and
every form of growth
entails a little bit of discomfort but
it can be an exhilarating experience
if you want to know more about learning
foreign languages better
faster and with more joy please check
out my channel there's hundreds of
videos you can watch and enjoy
thanks so much for watching and peace
and out
you